[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 les invités une
émission dédiée à celles et ceux qui
font l'actualité dans le département et
aujourd'hui mardi 18 avril parole à
jacqueline bonal membres du saint
quentin gospel elle nous présentera le
concert qui sera donné dans quelques
jours au prisme à elancourt un concert
donné au profit des restos du coeur 78
ans rival de l'association sera aussi en
plateau parole également dans cette
émission à jean-claude jamot président
du comité départemental de la randonnée
pédestre des yvelines nous évoquerons
avec lui à l'opération en randonnée est
organisée en ce moment par les
différents clubs du département et qui
vise à nettoyer les sentiers et les
chemins yvelinois ohrid fall et
jacqueline à bonal bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes respectivement responsable
manifestation pour les restos du coeur
78 et membre du saint-quentin gospel et
vous êtes donc ici en plateau pour nous
présenter ce concert qui sera donné le
29 avril au prix sema elle encourt un
concert du saint-quentin gospel au
profit des restos du coeur d'où votre
venue à tous les deux en plateau
expliquez-nous déjà peut-être la gêne
est ce de cette collaboration comment
vous est venue l'idée de faire ce
concert en sang il y a deux ans j'avais
assisté à un concert du saint-quentin
gospel et j'avais été enthousiasmé par
leur prestation et l'année dernière j'ai
demandé au saint quentin gospel s'il
pouvait chanter pour les restos du coeur
ils l'ont fait à poissy ils m'ont dit si
on a chanté à poissy on peut pas
retourner dans le nord du département on
peut mais par contre on peut chanter
dans le sud et donc il ya un le
président losier qui nous a prêté le
théâtre du prisme et je remercie le
président c'est un très beau cadeau et
donc on a le prisme le 29 avril et le
saint quentin gospel veut bien chanter
pour les restos du coeur le 29 avril
donc c'est la deuxième
une collaboration qui marche bien même
pour le saint quentin gospel ça
paraissait logique de s'associer à une
association caritative comme celle ci
complètement ça me fait partie de la
génèse aussi on a foncé les belles de
l'histoire de on a fait plusieurs
concerts pour des associations
caritatives et les restos du coeur c'est
quand même ça vous fasse ça nous parle
beaucoup vous bien sûr on re précise que
le concert est organisé le 29 avril à
partir de 20h30 au prisme à elancourt la
billetterie et est en ligne au tarif
unique de 15 euros la place du coup le
resto du coeur les restos du coeur et se
faire collecter combien avec ce concert
est ce que vous avez une fourchette une
idée oui oui autour de 7000 aux 7000
8000 euros vous voyez c'est beaucoup
enfin pour nous c'est beaucoup donc
justement avec cet argent qu est ce que
vous espérez financer faire et bien si
vous voulez on a on a besoin de trois
choses on a besoin de bénévoles sans
vous achète pas on a besoin de
nourriture
si on peut la collecter mais on a besoin
de moyens de transport de frigo de etc
et ça il faut les acheter donc on a
besoin d'argent
et aujourd'hui les besoins sont
importants dans le département des
yvelines
on a en a vu et on a des besoins oui le
premier besoin ses besoins en bénévoles
et je je je dis enfin j'veux pas
l'occasion et profite de 2,7
ce passage à la nage à l'antenne pour
dire qu'on a besoin de bénévoles à
l'entrepôt je te dire mais pour donner
diffère de la distribution données des
boîtes de conserve à des bénéficiaires
on arrive à trouver assez facilement
pour des gens qui se lève à 7h du matin
pour même peut-être plus tôt pour aller
très belle et des caisses à l'entrepôt
qui est aux clayes-sous-bois on a
beaucoup de mal pour faire la logistique
chauffeur de camion entrepôt donc si
vous êtes vous venez de passer à la
retraite si vous avez quelques
quelques muscles venez nous rejoindre on
a besoin de bénévoles et piémont tron
pourrait on pourrait peut-être croire
qu'on est dans un département assez
assez riche les yvelines ce qui est le
cas d'ailleurs mis à osciller vrai mais
voilà il ya des foyers de pauvreté ils y
en a deux grandes c'est la vallée de la
seine et puis toute la nationale 12 quoi
le trap etc
on va reparler un petit peu du gospel
pour ce concert du 29 avril
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter
dans les grandes lignes ce qu'est le
gospel pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
en quoi ça consiste peut-être sûr c'est
une musique très très ancienne puisque
c'est l'origine du gospel ce sont les
lèche enchanté par les noirs dans l'est
dans les champs de coton les negro
spirituals
ces gens-là chantait pour essayer de
survivre de se donner un petit podium au
logis et leurs conditions exactement
et puis le gospel à évoluer au fur et à
mesure des années des siècles pour
devenir un gospel plus contemporain
c'est une musique très élargi
aujourd'hui un finalement on va
peut-être aussi d'ailleurs on voir un
extrait tout de suite attention on va
voir on va pouvoir découvrir un petit
peu ce qu'est le gospel et puis sûrement
donner envie à certains téléspectateurs
ont regardé un extrait dessus d'un
ancien concert
[Musique]
là
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on vient on vient de le voir à l'écran
c'est un concert qui va bouger c'est ça
aussi le gospel c'est la bonne humeur la
bonne humeur pour une bonne action c'est
important de le souligner c'est pas
forcément quelque chose on reste assis
spectateurs c'est vraiment une musique
très participative
mais il peut y avoir des moments très
recueillie aussi selon les champs selon
les endroits dans lesquels on chante
aussi parce qu'il nous arrive aussi de
chanter dans des églises
ça peut vraiment revêtir un caractère
totalement différent selon les endroits
alors est ce qu on vous verra à vous
chantez d'ailleurs non moi n'ont
heureusement sinon il va il va pleuvoir
le saint quentin le gospel juste encore
un mot sur l'association c'est une
association qui marche plutôt bien et
qu'elle était depuis 1914 devront
participer maintenant à des festivals
internationaux absolument nous avons
participé à plusieurs festivals
international celui de chartres par
exemple des festivals de stockholm
festival de paris aussi
et
ce qu'ils sont des festivals qui
regroupe plus de 1000 choristes c'est
quelque chose vraiment quelque chose
d'extraordinaire de chanter dans des
conditions comme ça et de rencontres des
partages henri wallon on rappelle
peut-être les conditions pour ce concert
donc c'est le 29 avril à 20h30 et la
billetterie on peut se renseigner sur le
site internet de huy 78 l'aspect sur
google restos du coeur plus yvelines
vous tombez sur la fiche du spectacle
dessous il ya billetterie ou cliqué
billetterie vous payez par carte bleue
et vous imprimer votre billet quand vous
le dites salaire tout simple c'est sûr à
des 68 points restosducoeur.org et
peut-être que notre nouvel invité pour
cette émission sera intéressé par ce
concert donné à elancourt juste par
curiosité est ce que jean-claude jamot
vous connaissez la musique gospel est ce
que vous connaissiez la musique gospel
je connais très bien et j'ai apprécié
beaucoup aussi
voilà comme je suis voisin j'irai
certainement les écouter alors vous êtes
avec nous en plateau pas pour parler de
gospel mais d'une autre bonne action qui
se déroule en ce moment sur le
département
ces randos net une opération de
nettoyage des chemins et des sentiers
que vous parcourez vous en qualité de
randonneurs toute l'année c'est la
troisième fois que vous faites cette
opération rando net
concrètement dans quel état sont nos
chemins et nos sentiers dans les
yvelines et ce qu'ils sont dans un état
de délabrement ou alors j'exagère un
petit peu non alors déjà
nous les entretenons nous en tant que
fédération de randonnée pédestre
c'est en accord avec le conseil
départemental des yvelines que nous
faisons cette opération et non ils sont
en bon état mais les forêts en général
là c'est beaucoup plus désagréable le
randonneur de base est quelqu'un qui
aime la nature qui la protègent nous
sommes d'ailleurs agrées pour la
protection de l'environnement
mais cela étant on rencontre beaucoup de
gens aient enfin d'incivilité alors ça
fait trois ans que nous lançons cette
opération en partenariat avec le conseil
départemental et le wef
et j'irai malheureusement on récolte pas
mal de détritus justement parlez-nous un
peu de ces déchets qu'on peut trouver
dans la forêt j'imagine que vous avez
des anecdotes ou des petits délits et
trouvailles un peu malheureuse il ya des
grosses trouvailles mais ça pour les
grosses trouvaille du type carcasses de
voitures ou gravois il ya une opération
qui s'appelle suricates qui est national
et là toute personne qui se promène qui
est un portable n'a qu'a donné le
signalement est expliqué et on
intervient auprès des communes la minus
que l'on fait par exemple pour les
machines à laver ou les carcasses de
bovins vous pouvez pas évidemment leur
seul il n'a quand même pas trop en forêt
en yvelines savent passe à peu près bien
par contre beaucoup de cannes est enfin
de deux petites le petit détritus est là
donc on fournit des sacs aux gens on le
re au club on a 45 loeb dans les
yvelines qui participent complètement à
cette opération ils ont tout le mois
d'avril pour le faire et si au cours
d'une randonnée rando normal il y le
monde on va là on prend les sacs et et
or abbas donc on ne sait pas
exclusivement ramasser c'est aussi
marcher je veux dire d'influencé dont
les deux voilà exactement ils ne vont
pas pour ramasser les détritus il on
profite pour ramasser les détritus
ça fait quand même quatre mille
licenciés qui se promènent sur nos 1300
km de sentiers dans les yvelines
oui alors vous vous êtes randonneurs
depuis de nombreuses années oui est ce
que vous diriez quand même qu'avec le
temps
les gens changent de comportement et
qu'on a peut-être moins tendance à
acheter tout ce qu'on a entre les mains
et qu'on fait un peu plus attention on
fait un peu plus attention et nous une
trop lille et pédagogique justement on
se promène avec nos sacs sur lesquels il
ya vraiment la spécificité de ce que
l'on fait et donc on en profite pour
parler aux gens que l'on rencontre
je crois qu'il n'y a que comme ça qu'on
peut arriver vraiment interpeller les
gens d'ailleurs c'est pas uniquement les
membres de votre de vos clubs qui
peuvent partir en paix à randonnai tout
le monde peut y participer là tout le
monde et il ya beaucoup de municipalités
qui commence à vouloir s'accrocher à
notre système si vous voulez et pour
participer aussi à la propreté générale
lors ce qui est important c'est que les
sacs on ramène les détritus et on les
trie on les ramène d'ailleurs chaque
personne les ramène chez elle et fait le
tri donc c'est vraiment un processus
clean nos sacs sont en amidon de maïs
bio dégradable on laisse aucune casse il
ya un vrai volet écologique tout à fait
que vous disiez que la situation
s'améliore dans les sentiers mais il
faut pour ce que j'imagine tout de même
la pédagogie est ce qu'il ya des gestes
simples d habitude qu'on pourrait perdre
très facilement selon vous des choses
qu'il est de jeter par exemple les
mouchoirs en papier les par exemple mais
je pense que tout randonneur à un sac
plastique tourner une pochette pour
mettre ce qu'il convient pas mais sa
douce et c'est automatique
c'est ccc dans notre esprit voilà donc
ça c'est sûr qu'il faut avoir un sac à
dos et il ya de quoi mettre plein de
choses dedans vous le disiez ça a
commencé début avril c'est jusqu'à la
fin bruxelles a toujours l'ensemble du
silence dans les yvelines
oui on peut trouver plus d'information
cette fois ci sur votre site internet de
sites internet www.co néraudeau 78
points à ce au point fr fr merci à vous
trois d'être venu en plateau merci à
tous c'est la fin de ce set 8 les
invités pour ce soir prochain rendez
vous demain d'ici là nos ces camps sont
à retrouver en replay sur notre site
internet tv fil 78 points comme
excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]